- [Instructor] We are now going
to discuss price elasticity
of demand, which sounds
like a very fancy concept,
but really, it's a way
for economists to sense
how sensitive is quantity
to change in prices.
And in this video, we're gonna
denote it as a capital E,
so E, price elasticity of demand.
And the easy way to think about it is
it is your percent change
in, I'll use the Greek letter
delta as shorthand for change in here,
percent change in quantity over
your percent change in price.
And so, you might say,
wait, how does this relate
to the everyday idea of elasticity?
Well, imagine two bands.
So, let's imagine an inelastic band,
inelastic, right over
here, and let's imagine
an elastic band right over here.
So, in an inelastic band, if
we apply some amount of force,
you're not going to be
able to stretch it much,
it might stretch a little
bit, while an elastic band,
if you apply that same amount of force,
you might be able to
stretch it a lot more.
And so, the analogy here
is we're not using force,
but we're saying how much
does quantity stretch
for a given amount of price change?
And so, something where
the quantity changes a lot
for a given price change
would be very elastic.
So, this, the magnitude
of this will be larger.
And if the percent change in
quantity doesn't change a lot
for a our given percent change in price,
well, then we're dealing with an inelastic
price elasticity of demand.
And we'll be able to
internalize these more
as we work through the numbers.
And actually, let's do that for this
demand schedule that we
have right over here,
and it's visualized as our demand curve.
In the vertical axis, we
have price of burgers;
and then in our horizontal axis,
we have quantity, in
terms of burgers per hour.
And so, let's just use
this definition of price
elasticity of demand to calculate it
across different points
on our demand curve.
So, I'm gonna make a new column here,
so price elasticity of demand.
And the way I'm gonna do it is really
the simplest method for calculating this.
In other videos, we can go into more
in-depth methods, like
the midpoint method.
And I'll show you the weakness
in what we're doing right here.
But for the sake of, say, an AP economics,
microeconomics course,
this would be sufficient.
So, let's think about our
price elasticity of demand
as we go from point A to point B.
Well, remember, that's just
going to be our percent change
in quantity over our
percent change in price.
So, what is our percent
change in quantity?
Well, we're starting at a quantity of two,
so I'll put that in our denominator.
And we're going from two to
four, so we are adding two.
So, we have two over two, we could
multiply that times 100% if we like.
So, this would give us, we
have 100% change in quantity
over, now what was the corresponding
change in price, percent change in price?
So, our corresponding
percent change in price,
our initial price is nine,
and we go from nine to eight,
so we're going down by one.
And then we multiply that times 100%.
So, this is going to
be about a negative 11%
change in price.
And this math is
reasonably straightforward
because the 100%s cancel
out, this is just a one.
One over negative 1/9 is just going
to be equal to negative nine.
So, you have a negative nine
price elasticity of demand.
So, before I interpret that more,
let's look at the price
elasticity of demand
at other points, or
starting from other points
to other points on this curve.
So, let's think about it going from,
actually let's think about
it going from E to F.
So, as we go from E to F, we're going
to do the same exact exercise.
What is our percent change in quantity?
Well, our initial quantity is 16.
And we're going from 16 to 18,
so we have a change of two.
So, two over 16 times 100%,
that is our percent change in quantity.
And what is our percent change in price?
Well, our initial price is two.
And we're going from two to one,
so we have a price change
of negative one times 100%.
And so, what you see here
is this is 1/8 times 100%,
this would be 12.5% up here.
So, this is 12.5% up there, and then this,
over here, is going to be negative 50%.
So, when price went down by 50%,
you had a 12.5% increase in quantity.
12.5% is 1/4 of 50%, so
this is going to give us
a price elasticity of
demand of negative 0.25.
So, there's a couple of interesting things
that you might already be realizing.
One is even though our
demand curve right over here
is a line, it actually
has a constant slope,
you see that the price
elasticity of demand changes,
depending on different parts of the curve.
Now, the reason why this is,
is really just boils down to math.
When we're going from A to B,
our initial prices were relatively high.
So, even though you had
a price decrease of one,
it was from an initial price of nine.
So, your percentage change
in price looked fairly low,
while your percentage
change in quantity was high
'cause you're going from
a low quantity of two,
and you're adding two to it,
so you had 100% change in quantity.
When you go to the other end our curve,
and you go from E to F,
it's the other way around.
Your price starting point is low,
so your percent change in price,
when you decrease price by one,
it looks like a fairly large magnitude;
while your percent change in quantity
when you go from E to F
because you are already
at a quantity of 16, adding two to that
is not that large of a percentage.
Now, another thing you
might be appreciating
is if we tried to calculate
the price elasticity of demand
up here on the curve, and
instead of going from A to B,
if we went from B to A, we would've gotten
a different value because
our initial prices
and quantities would have been different.
Our initial price, we would've
put an eight right over here,
and our initial quantity, we
would've put a four over here,
and we would've gotten a different value.
And that's one of the
negatives of the technique,
which is arguably the simplest
technique, that I just used.
There's other techniques,
like the midpoint technique,
that can give you a
more consistent result,
whether you're going
from A to B or B to A,
but I won't cover it just yet.
But let's think, now, about
how to interpret this.
And the best way to
interpret it is to think
about the absolute value of
the price elasticity of demand.
So, over here, the absolute value of our
price elasticity of
demand is equal to nine,
and then, over here, the absolute value
of our price elasticity of
demand is equal to 0.25.
And a general rule of thumb
is if your absolute value
of your price elasticity
of demand is less than one,
you are dealing with an
inelastic, inelastic,
elastic situation;
and if your price elasticity of demand,
the absolute value of
it, is greater than one,
you're dealing with an elastic situation.
Why does that make sense?
Well, in this first scenario, it's saying
for a given percentage change in price,
you have a smaller percent
change in quantity;
while here, for a given percent in price,
you're going to have a larger than that
percentage change in your quantity.
So, once again, it goes back
to these rubber band analogies.
So, when we're going from A to B,
the absolute value of our
price elasticity of demand
is definitely larger than one.
So, economists would consider this
to be an elastic situation;
while when we go from point E to point F,
our price elasticity of demand,
or the absolute value of it,
is definitely less than one,
so this going to be an
inelastic situation.